and we're following two hurricanes in
the Atlantic this morning that could
affect millions of Americans Jose and
Maria are category 1 hurricane x' with
sustained winds of at least 85 miles per
hour
now Jose is east of the Carolinas and
could hit the Northeast with tropical
storm force winds later this week but
Maria is expected to strengthen to a
major hurricane and could be very bad
news for Caribbean islands that are just
still recovering from Emma David Beck
knows in San Juan Puerto Rico where
hurricane watch is now in effect David
good morning Gail good morning the
sunrise is a little deceiving over this
beachfront resort area this islands in
hurricane mode in fact that building
right there with boards on it they put
those boards on for Emma which passed by
Puerto Rico two weeks ago they're going
to leave them up for Maria the beach is
clear right now schools are closed
government workers will be allowed to go
home today between 11:00 and 1:00 to get
ready for the next storm there are 450
shelters that are open and in fact
people are still at those shelters and
plan to stay there as Maria looks to
make a direct hit the US territory of
Puerto Rico escaped a direct hit from
hurricane
but the storm still knocked out power to
about 70% of the island nearly two
thousand US citizens who live or were
vacationing in the US Virgin Islands
were evacuated to Puerto Rico following
Erla including more than 500 people who
arrive by cruise ship on Thursday across
the Caribbean many of the islands in the
path of Hurricane Maria look like this
Tortola and the British Virgin Islands
is still covered in debris when you get
to the bottom you have nowhere to go but
up but it's one board one stick one log
one brick at a time we have yet another
hurricane forecast to hit the British
Virgin Islands Sir Richard Branson whose
Island home was badly damaged by Emma
has been raising money and awareness for
the battered British territory
he says rebuilding is going to be a
massive
but right now the focus is on the
immediate threat of Maria everyone's
been running around trying to you know
try to create some kind of shelter if
and when the next hurricane comes and
you know they are protected back here in
Puerto Rico consider this
Irma went about a hundred miles north of
the island yet they still lost the
majority of the power seventy seventy
five percent so Charlie imagine what's
going to happen if Maria stays on track
for a direct hit David II beg no in
Puerto Rico David thank you